( music playing )
( squeals)
( panting )
I think I need bigger lungs.
How do you like
my sandcastle, Lucy?
It's not very realistic.
No one could ever live
in a castle like that.
( muttering )
( grown-up talking )
No, ma'am.
I'm not going in the water yet.
I just like being prepared.
I even brought
this appropriately
themed novelty cup
full of fluids,
so I can ensure I stay
properly hydrated.
( sighs )
H20.
Sally, have you
seen my beach ball?
I just let for Hawaii.
Snoopy,
if you're going surfing,
I don't want you
going out too far.
And no riding the big waves,
only the small ones.
Surf's up!
Woohoo!
And no carving the A-frames!
Or hanging ten!
And no hot-dogging,
if you'll pardon the expression.
Woohoo! Cowabunga!
( laughing )
Looking good, Snoopy.
( grunting )
Woohoo!
( chittering )
Woohoo-hoo-hoo!
Say, Snoopy's doing
all right out there.
I can't bear to look.
( squeals )
Watch out!
- ( grunting )
- Can I look now?
I wouldn't, Charlie Brown.
- Snoopy's about to...
- Wipe out!
( gasps )
Oh.
Ahh.
( laughing )
( groans )
( chittering )
( yawn )
Snoopy, over here!
You can swim back
if you want.
He can probably walk back.
What a goofball.